the whole truth okay so the boy spin-off
genv just dropped its fourth episode and
it's one of my favorite entries in both
series teeken night is here and though
they do some changes to the comic
counterpart I think the way they take
things is absolutely hilarious yeah he's
a Sherlock Holmes esque parody who's
constantly overanalyzing things and over
analyzing things just stay away from the
top
five we will get into it all and bring
you the whole meaning behind it but
obviously heavy spoilers ahead for what
happens in the episode if you enjoy the
breakdown then please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
videos on the show every week without
the way I'm your host Paul now let's get
into genv episode
4 now we begin in the aftermath of last
week's final episode however rather than
seeing the Escape we see Sam and Emma
have already made it out last time said
he knew the codes of the doors and this
is how they managed to get out so easily
I'm guessing that as the series goes
ahead and they need to get back in that
he's going to be the one who can open it
all up now we begin with Emma's victim
and see that a light's able to shine
through from one side of his head to the
other Emma crawled all the way through
but at the moment they only think Sam's
involved the scientists determined Sam
might have skull [__] him and we see
what technik got up to towards the end
of the video which involved something
with a skull don't worry if you're not
up to speed on the comics by the way
don't trouble yourself here we'll talk
about tech knite later on and what
happened in the source material anyway
shedy instantly knows it isn't Samu did
it and she finds some his shoes almost
catching her red-handed or or footed
outside we cut to a crater in the ground
where Maran Co discover the tracker
these impact points have appeared
throughout comic book movies with Hulk
Mo notably creating them when he hits
the ground this is due to how strong Sam
is which allows him to jump across great
distances which we see him doing when he
leaves a drive through later on Queen ma
also created cracks like this too which
Andre brings up when discussing the
impact points maybe Sam can jump like M
does he landed here with Emma and then
jumped again the rankings have been
updated as well with Andre still being
at the top and Marie's gone to number
two really doesn't matter though and
instead what the focus is on is the fact
that the woods are doing something to
the kids turns out the school is a
[__] mangle at health clinic now in
case you don't know Mangler was a German
scientist that carried out human
experiments during World War II it's
super [__] what he did and a lot of
them involved using children compound V
was of course also developed by the
Nazis and it was likely created through
experiments like this carried out by
people like mangl makes you wonder what
they were doing with Sam's back last
week and I've got a few time now they're
trying to find a way to disable or
paralyze the soups we've got lots of
them with the potential to become super
villains and we've seen how elmara and
Sage Grove have struggled to contain
them there's been lots of deaths and
thus they may have been trying to make a
way to take out these Rogue soups this
would pay off bigger in the main season
with it potentially being a weapon that
could finally take down homelander I
feel like soja boy was the best chance
they had but even that didn't stop him
so they have to look at more Extreme
Measures anyway that's
anything we'll be doing more times later
on but a now Jordan says that because
Brink was in on it shedy could be too
and we see her getting much closer to
Marie throughout these episodes Jordan
also jokes about them getting a dog in a
green man and I was thinking Scooby
dooby-doo where are you Al though they
suspect that Emma could be dead we see
she's alive in well Along With Sam cut
to an establishing shot of where they're
camped out at and we can see on the
driveing sign that they're showing red
Thunder this was a parody of Rambo tree
and Red Zone and it's centered around
the Soviet Afghan war going over to the
V YouTube channel you can actually watch
2 minutes of this in full before it was
then adapted into the show Sam says he
used to come and watch movies here with
his brother and I also also believe we
can catch a photo of soldier boy in the
newspapers lining the windows now this
is where Sam finds out L is dead which
further plays into how he feel like
everyone always leaves him the trust he
has for Emma is something I think will
come into conflict with her potentially
having to choose between him and her
career as we know she's getting offer
jobs doing reality TV stuff and becoming
the star she always wanted to be making
YouTube video sure I I enjoy it h but
this could give her something that's
actually legitimate and now she turned
it down but there may be other
opportunities and I'm guessing we're
going to hit a point where she'll have
to pick between the two now from here we
C to the Vault plus intro of tech Knight
show which is called the whole truth
going to say it this is one of my
favorite characters in both the comic
and other Series so funny watching the
Sherlock Holmes parody which is a
direction I wasn't expecting them to
take Tech Knight originally debuted in
the first boys Omnibus during the get
some Arc but it was pretty much just
your standard Batman parody yeah though
he's constantly overanalyzing things and
acting like Sherlock did in his show and
movie adaptations now in the comics we
begin with him satin therapy session
where he says I can't stop [__]
things and this kind of plays into his
entire Arc and like the show we discover
he has a brain tumor this makes him want
to stick his dick in every hole he sees
which I think the series plays perfectly
off of he's constantly looking at things
with holes and obsessing over them and
just staring at them long inly whilst
rubbing around the ring also on the
first panel you can see the therapist
drinking Jitter beans which Emma and
Marie both drank in episode 2 be careful
though cuz as we learn in the comics
this is one of the things Tech Knight
[__] later on when Tech threaten
Shetty he picks up a donut and stares
lovingly at the round hole in it on the
table we can see a coffee cup as well
tying this whole thing together with his
intro in the comics now for this part of
the video I want to briefly go through
what happens in The Source material and
and where it eventually leads to because
his his final is it's very funny now in
the session we learn he's one of the
founding members of payack and when they
were out flying once he noticed mind
Droid had a great ass attempting to bang
it he was suspended from the group and
we learn about his obsession over hols
turned out he [__] a chinchilla to
death and was getting pretty close to
going after his sidekick ladio shout
outs to editor Matt for also noticing
that you could catch a ladio comic
during episode 3 now while this was
going on the boys started to investigate
him and it's also during this time that
they first met the legend we learned
that Tech Knight in assult sidekick had
a threesome with a Catwoman parody named
the Talon and this caused tension to
flare between the pair that laddio had
gone on to become swing wi and Nightwing
parody whilst Tech Knight got someone
new now Ved marketed swing wi is the
first gay hero but all of this was just
for p cuz swing wi was straight turned
out he'd somewhat led to the death of a
man who confessed his love for him and
this is what the boys had been
investigating Tech Knight had actually
applied to join the seven but swing wi
informed them of his tumor so he never
got to be part of the team traveling to
his Mansion we saw his Butler Tomic
moving out after Tech well well he did
something to his ear but soon after huy
and buter showed up and immediately
walked in and opened up his cave Tech
Knight was masquerading as a billionaire
playboy but buter already knew his
identity in advance now eventually the
truth was brought to the light about all
this stuff been up to going back to the
cave Kimo kicked the crap out of him
which is when he talked about what
happened with the old ltio now they SED
swinging out and we cut to Tech KN night
walking along the street which is when
he saved a mother and child from a
falling wheelbarrow at that moment
asteroids started hitting the Earth and
he immediately lapped into action and
traveled into space seeing of a jj-
shaped crevice he then started [__]
it which destroyed the asteroid and then
saved the planet in the end Tech Knight
was a hero with his sacrifice saving
billions and though he died he died a
hero's death you're my boy
blue you're my boy now what really
happened was yeah the wheelbarrow
smacked him on the head and killed him
the carut found the giant tumor and this
explained all the stuff that was going
on with him it's really stupid but quite
funny and yet this TV show it takes it
in a hilarious Direction and I do kind
of hope they release the the full clip
of it on YouTube it makes a really deep
impact and you could say the guy's
favorite game is asteroids F this
man in the csis True Crime intro he
talks about all the alumni at the school
and this includes Queen mave the deep
and a train along with himself never
seen his actor before but he knocks it
out the park delivering whole insects
puns throughout the entire thing and I
won't stop plunging its depths until I
get
there all in Dean ched's room we see a
bus of queen mave and the stained glass
windows featuring the soups the idea of
God you of course contains the word God
and these windows evoke the idea that
this is like a church Tech Knight he
instantly sees through the BS at the
school and over analyes she says she's
got nothing to hide adrenaline seeping
from your pores and you're ovulating by
the
way from what they say Tech Knight's
completely brutal and he often beats a
paralyzes those who are under
investigation I kind of feel this plays
of how Batman brutally beats up those
he's after and leaves them with broken
Limbs and damaged organs either way
Ash's extended them unrival access to
the school but in the end he has to set
up a Psy the group's aren having a good
time either and we see Andre going to
katees completely high as [__] at this
point he tells her that his dad knows
about the woods but she does argue that
he might be trying to protect him all he
sees though is a fake hero who acts like
one in the movies but fails to live up
to it in real life I think the boys has
been brilliant about breaking down
celebrity culture and how we'll often
hear about the hypocrisy lay throughout
entertainment people can act and come
across as a hero but if trouble actually
starts they often look the other way now
from here we cut do a whole truth
episode talking about a soup known as
sheoth this is obviously a shehulk
parody with her being a blue skin
version of the comic book character
shaho actually appeared in the boys
comic as well with her dropping by
during the pages of herogasm leaving her
lover a stain on the floor this might be
a play on the Netflix documentary called
killer Sally this was a bodybuilder who
murdered her husband who also happened
to be in the industry as well think the
whole truth stuff's clearly riffing on
the making of murdery style dos that
turned crime into entertainment and
don't really care about the actual
issues pulling out we see Marie going to
the psychic Rufus who I think has the
name cuz it's similar to ruy guy's a
predator that makes Marie black out and
wake up in his room while he's wearing a
rug now obviously I can't show what
happens but it's one of the most
memorable things to to pop off in the
boys man's man's dick explodes and yeah
I doubt I'll get that out of my head for
a while now I will talk about this
blacking out later on as it kind of
plays into what happens at the end
potentially Rufus was involved and we'll
go over the theories about what happened
there might not though cuz I don't know
how anyone could have survive that
either way Jordan banging on the door
seems like it snaps Marie out of it and
the pair then walk along the Corridor
after the [__] explosion elsewhere we
see Andre's brought before Tech Knight
who begins interrogating the group me
me is this my friend just the whole way
they play it as a TV show but also life
and death it works so well to show how
dangerous for it is everyone's life is
on the line here and even giving the
wrong answer could cause a lot of issues
each of the main groups brought in for
questioning with Kate getting nervous
and almost removing her glove take that
glove off I take your [__] hand off
so intense and Tech also picks up that
Andre and Kate have been well how long
have you been eating golden boy's
girlfriend's hole well notice how he
says hole cuz the man's got that
underlying Obsession now Andre bites
tech for not being a true hero which
also somewhat reflects his dad's
cowardice everyone's just a scared
little boy who's desperate to not Anno
vot and get punished for the
Disobedience Elmyra in the woods shows
what happens if soup step out of line
and then are unable to actually be
heroes now back at the drive-in we see
Sam standing in front of a poster for
red Thunder 2 which has the tagline pay
back a back in total they made three red
Thunder films before the group had what
happened to them in season 3 go down and
the PIR joke back and forth but Darkness
starts to creep in when we hear what
sounds like ice cream van music later on
we see inside of Sam's vision and
watches he's haunted by Sesame Street
parodies in this we see Jason rder and a
deep puppet making fun of how he's
unable to protect people later on WE C
to him encountering these after a shot
in which he looks out through the
drive-through window here we can catch a
picture of soldier boy and Crimson
Countess and one for polarity just down
to the left on Avenue V we also see
puppet versions of the deep skill and
they tell him to kill the scientists
that experimented on him this leads us
towards what happens in the finale and
with his name being Dr kadosa it
explains why that week's letter is K now
back at the school we see Marie going to
superhero branding which is the subject
of tech Knight's interrogation Dean shed
somewhat puts her under one to asking if
there's anything that Emma's been up to
she lies and says she's been staying at
a guys but when it comes down to being
spoke to by Tech she instantly starts
cracking hilarious how he rubs the ring
on the cell tape and then goes into
talking about what what happened with
Luke not the whole story again hle and
he starts picking the holes in Marie's
story Focus ing on the classic signs
that show someone's lying he basically
comes across as one of those human lie
detectors often they say focus on key
factors like pupils dilating and people
getting tense admitting that it was
Jordan who saved her from Luke it puts a
dent in the armor that she's a true hero
now Tech says the top five could end up
being real eres and thus he's planning
to pin it all on Shetty after all she
let Sam escape and him she is just a
human again I'm kind of constantly being
pulled back to what they're actually
doing the words and thinking about the
overall story in the comics I will talk
about this at the end of the video but I
think there's something happening
building into the bigger picture I'll
say that for the spoiler section though
in case you're still reading it but yeah
lots of things that I think we need to
talk about anyway across campus Andre
crushes his dad statue's head which
riffs on a young Magneto crushing the
helmet in first class it truly
represents what he feels about his
father and ultimately how he views a
statue as a false idol elsewhere we see
Jordan meeting with Marie with the pair
discussing their actual feelings Jordan
is someone who's been brought up in a
system where they've been forced to
conform and fit in a certain way whether
it's their parents or bring training
them to be in the top 10 every single
aspect of them is being controlled but
unfortunately no one really accepts them
and both their dad and V see them as
being someone who doesn't quite fit in
their dad gave the idea that he just
wanted a son and V didn't want to
getting out that Jordan stole Luke still
though Jordan is stayed Shackled to the
system but they are finally starting to
be themselves now on the other side of
this is Marie who's been desperate to
fit in because she's been Outcast since
getting her powers whether it was her
sister or or the adoption home that took
her in everything's kind of been put in
place to keep her apart from society now
she's finally getting there but realizes
it's not all it's crack to be which is a
similar Ro that Starlight went on the
pairs start getting it on which is when
Emma walks in and she tells them about
where Sam's going going in the words we
see Tech Knight meeting up with Shetty
and she asks if he's recently visited
John Hopkins this is a university
similar to God youu which explains why
she'd be able to access his medical
records since gaining his brain tumor
he's been hitting more holes than Tiger
Woods and he even went to the skull in
shed's office if it got out it would
ruin his career and then she blackmails
him into keeping things quite he's been
despoiling stuff doing the opposite to
me unless he just goes with a story that
Luke was just crazy we end with him
barking up the wrong tree both literally
and figuratively and hopefully we see
him back either there in this series or
popping up in the main one would love to
see him interacting with the seven and
hey I know they've got a couple of spare
members left so yeah get the guy in now
at the Docks we see Sam's broken in but
before things really kick off the heroes
show up Sam calls them all puppets and
this explains why he views the world the
way he does he sees everyone as being
controlled by a corporation and they've
oppressed those that they're unable ble
to hold in place a big fight breaks out
with a kitchen getting smashed up which
leads to everything going out into the
garden Sam goes giant woman and pins him
down but mids sentence everything cuts
to Black
we'll waking up next to Jordan we play
out a montage of tech Knight getting his
hair dried the other hair and and you
probably have a hell of a lot of
questions so that takes us again in a
the time the time the time is a
yes it is now I think that Rufus will
probably be revealed as being the one
behind it due to the power set we see
him demonstrating in the episode in both
instances we see the screen cut to Black
with Marie coming to completely unaware
of how she got there though initially he
said that she had to come in close for
it to work we've seen how the soups can
go super sign when the situation calls
for it potentially Rufus is being used
to keep certain things suppressed in the
school which is why they've looked the
other way when it comes to what he's up
to Jordan knew about it and I'm guessing
that those were two due to how much of
an eye the higher ups keep on the
students now Rufus was taken out he was
taken out pretty brutally and I do have
some doubt over whether he could have
survived this didn't seem like it had
though and Marie would be under
investigation for his death so I don't
know if that's the way they're going to
take things now there's some Easter eggs
I missed in the entry and shout outs to
edit a map for catching them when we
were working on the video he picked up
on shedy mentioning icast who was a
Colossus parody that appeared in the
boys diabolical he also spotted that the
drive-through logo looked like Planet
Hollywood and that Avenue V was based on
Avenue Q which itself is assess Myster
parody shout outs to Matt as always and
for the next part of the video I want to
give my thoughts on the entry before we
dive into the comic spoilers so you can
at least get the review in case you
don't want to know now Tech Knight's
someone I've wanted to see in the show
ever since the debuted as is arcs one of
the most memorable things in the
original comic when I first read it I
thought the opening issues were okay but
when it hit that point it just got
incredible that's also when the legend
was introduced and you slowly start to
learn about what was happening with the
seven creating this Batman parody was
something I found hilarious and I was
expecting them to make a character along
the same lines however I love the
direction they took it and seeing them
pick apart Sherlock was a hilarious way
to take things the series is also going
in a really interesting Direction too
and I wasn't expecting it to take some
of the turns it did I love how the
schools kind of little upt version of
war with its own Secrets happening there
too considering all the main cast or
original Creations as well I'm actually
surprised at how much they've matched up
to the comic book ones I think it's
probably way easier to make a TV show
based on characters who've appeared in
the comics but the fact they haven't and
still here at the level they do it just
works really well again another great
episode and I'm really excited to see
where they go with it I feel like the
boys is the strongest comic book
property we have right now and it's
really showing how you make a TV show
with interesting characters in plot
lines now speaking of plot we might be
getting things going in line with the
comics which I will be talking about for
for the end part of the video you don't
want to know then turn off now and huge
thank you for watching until this point
now in the comics the boys ended up
discovering a way to destroy the soups
which involved triggering a certain
element within V that caused their heads
to explode this is where I thought they
were going with Victoria and potentially
they they could be tying that together
the comics culminated with butcher
attempted to set off a radio frequency
which could kill every soup on the
planet I think they might end up taking
things in that direction with the woods
being something that could be where
humans are studying how to weaken soups
the guards of Sonic emits which can
disable characters and they've also been
carrying out their own experiments
compound V is obviously injected into
your bloodstream and I'm wondering if
Marie might be related to this this
being this idea of blood lace throughout
the show with us even ending episode
three with Emma covered in it blood was
how Marie's Powers were birthed and
we've even seen with Rufus how strong
she can control it when it's in
someone's body compound V created so
many soups that there's far too many now
to keep under control though facilities
like Elmyra Sage Groves in the woods
have been set up they aren't exactly
soup proof and these Arkham Asylum esque
locations operate with the same
revolving or policy I think in the end
the company see wiping out the soups as
being the only way forward and then
they'll not run the risk of creating
soldja boy situations rather than having
to imprison them run the risk of
creating super villains I think that
will be the ultimate goal but obviously
let me know your thoughts I'd also love
to hear what you think on the show and
with us being at the halfway point
already let us know if you're enjoying
it please drop a like on the video and
if you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
you want to get some heavy spoilers
merch we've also got our t-shirt line
located below the video and that will
let you pick up all kinds of different
tops got Theory times ones House of
dragon Ahsoka Marvel te's and a lot more
so definitely check it out as it
massively helps us out if you want some
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the first three
episodes as there's lots of things in
that that kind of set up where we're
going out of the way thank you for Sing
sh the video I've been poor I'll see you
next time you better come back by
episode 5 you you better be back mate
you're making a promise right now cuz
you're watch this bit you take care
peace